في مقاطعة لوس أنجلوس ، يوجد أكثر من 60.000
شخص بلا مأوى في متوسط ​​الليل
وأكثر من 20000 غرفة فندقية
فارغة في متوسط ​​الليل ،
انظر إلى أين قد يحدث
هذا ، إنه مجرد جنون أم أنه
لن يحل المشكلة نحن  أعتقد أن هذا
جزء من الحل بأي حال من الأحوال ،
لا نعتقد أن هذا يحل أزمة التشرد ،
ولكن هل الفنادق لديها دور
تلعبه بالطبع ، فإن النقابة التي يقودها
والتي تجمع ممثلي الفندق ما يكفي من
التواقيع وسيقوم Angelenos بالتصويت على
مشروع القانون  من شأنه أن يجبر
كل فندق في المدينة على الإبلاغ عن الوظائف الشاغرة
في الساعة 2 مساءً كل يوم ، ثم
يرحب بالمشردين في تلك
الغرف الشاغرة بأمانة ، هل ستسجل دخولك
إلى فندق مع العلم أن فرصة
جارك
على اليسار أو اليمين هي أن يكون شخصًا بلا مأوى
يدير باتيل طواعية بعض الإيجارات
غرف للأشخاص المشردين الذين تم فحصهم ودفع تكاليفهم من
قبل الكنيسة المحلية ، لكنه
ضد هذا القانون الذي سيجعل ذلك
إلزاميًا ، فنحن بالكاد نعيش في المرتبة
الأولى رقم اثنين
علينا أن  فكر في سلامة
موظفينا والثالث ، نحن لسنا
مهنياً أو بأي طرق أخرى
مجهزين بأي من آليات الدعم
التي سيطلبها الضيف المشرد
ما هي الخدمات التي سيتم تقديمها ،
لا يزال من غير الواضح أيضًا أن
التمويل والفنادق ستدفع بالسوق العادل
قيم الأمر متروك للمدينة ، أعني أنهم فعلوا
ذلك أثناء مفتاح غرفة المشروع ، انتهى
الآن برنامج عصر الوباء الذي
ألهم هذه الفاتورة من خلال وضع أكثر من
عشرة آلاف شخص في الفنادق التي
تطوعت شون بيج دلهي بينهم
جيدًا أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، إنها نعمة.
إنها غرفة رائعة ، التكنولوجيا
ليست على قدم المساواة ولكنك تعرف ما هي التقنيات
التي لديك في الخيمة ، وهذا القانون
سيجبر المطورين أيضًا على استبدال المساكن
المهدمة لإفساح المجال لفنادق جديدة
وسيتم تقديم تصاريح الفنادق
بالإضافة إلى جعل كل فندق  من
الثمانية الكبار إلى بيلتمور باستثناء
الأشخاص
الذين لا مأوى لهم كضيوف ، لا أعتقد أن هذه فكرة جيدة ،
لماذا لا يكون ذلك ممكنًا بالنسبة للبعض ولكنك تعلم أن
هناك الكثير من  الناس الذين لم يتم علاجهم من
الصحة العقلية
وبعض الناس يلحقون بعض الضرر بهذه المباني الفقيرة ،
حدث هذا في إدارة فندق باتيل
وقد قامت بتمييز جميع الجدران
أه ستائر أحرقت الحمد لله لم
يكن هناك حريق
حتى تميز السقف المعارضين
لإيواء المشردين في الفنادق يخشون هذا
ويخشى أن يتم تأجيل السائحين حتى من
القدوم إلى إل.أ لا أريد أن يتواجد أطفالي
حول أشخاص لست متأكدًا من
أنني لا أريد أن أكون في مصعد مع
شخص من الواضح أنه يعاني من كسر عقلي
فكرة أنك  يمكن أن يختلط
الأشخاص المشردون بدفع
الغاز الطبيعي ،
فهذا لا ينجح ، فنحن لا نريد
العودة إلى الجنوب المعزول ،
لكن هذا نوع من اللغة
التي يتحدثون عنها هناك
فئة معينة من الناس أقل من البشر
الحيوانات  تقريبًا يصفون الفوضى لكي يكونوا
صادقين معك ، لا يبدو أنهم
يفهمون من هم الأشخاص غير المسكنين.
نتحدث مرة أخرى عن الطلاب الأكبر سنًا ،
الأشخاص الذين يعملون والذين
سيفيد برنامج القسائم  عظم